The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All
right, today we're
going to do an exciting
topic, which is hashing.
Do it all in one
lecture, that's the plan.
See if we make it.
You've probably
heard about hashing.
It's probably the most
common data structure
in computer science.
It's covered in pretty much
every algorithms class.
But there's a lot
to say about it.
And I want to
quickly review things
you might know and then
quickly get to things
you shouldn't know.
And we're going to
talk on the one hand
about different kinds
of hash functions,
fancy stuff like
k-wise independence,
and a new technique that's
been analyzed a lot lately,
simple tabulation hashing,
just in the last year.
And then we'll look
at different ways
to use this hash function that
actually build data structures,
chaining is the obvious
one; perfect hashing you
may have seen; linear probing
is another obvious one,
but has only been
analyzed recently;
and cuckoo hashing is a new one
that has its own fun feature.
So that's where we're
going to go today
Remember, the basic
idea of hashing
is you want to reduce
a giant universe
to a reasonably small table.
So I'm going to call
our hash function h.
I'm going to call the universe
integer 0 up to u minus 1.
So this is the universe.
And I'm going to denote the
universe by a capital U.
And we have a table
that we'd like to store.
I'm not going to draw
it yet because that's
the second half of the lecture,
what is the table actually.
But we'll just think of it as
indices 0 through m minus 1.
So this is the table size.
And probably, we want
m to be about n. n
is the number of keys we're
actually storing in the table.
But that's not necessarily
seen at this level.
So that's a hash function.
m is going to be
much smaller than u.
We're just hashing
integers here,
so if you don't have integers
you map your whatever space
of things you have to integers.
That's pretty much
always possible.
Now, best case scenario would
be to use a totally random hash
function.
What does totally random mean?
The probability, if you
choose your hash function,
that any key x maps to
any particular slot--
these table things
are called slots--
is 1 over m.
And this is
independent for all x.
So this would be ideal.
You choose each h of x for
every possible key randomly,
independently.
Then that gives you
perfect hashing.
Not perfect in
this sense, sorry.
It gives you ideal hashing.
Perfect means no collisions.
This actually might
have collisions,
there's some chance that two
keys hash to the same value.
We call this totally random.
This is sort of the
ideal thing that we're
trying to approximate with
reasonable hash functions.
Why is this bad?
Because it's big.
The number of bits
of information
you'd need if you actually
could flip all these coins,
you'd need to write
down, I guess U times
log m bits of information.
Which is generally way too big.
We can't afford U.
The whole point is
we want to store n items much
smaller than U. Surprisingly,
this concept will
still be useful.
So we'll get there.
Another system you've probably
seen is universal hashing.
This is a constraint
on hash function.
So this would be
ideally you'd choose h
uniformly at random
from all hash functions.
That would give you
this probability.
We're going to make a
smaller set of hash functions
whose size is much smaller.
And so you can encode the hash
function in many fewer bits.
And the property we want
from that hash family
is that if you look
at the probability
that two keys collide,
you get roughly what
you expect from totally random.
You would hope for 1 over m.
Once you pick one
key, the probability
the other key would hit
it would be 1 over m.
But we'll allow constant factor.
And also allow it to be smaller.
It gives us some slop.
You don't have to do this.
If you don't do this you it's
called strongly universal.
That's universal.
And universal is enough
for a lot of things
that you've probably seen, but
not enough for other things.
So here are some examples
of hash functions
that are universal, which
again, you may have seen.
You can take a random
integer a, multiply it
by x integer multiplication.
You could also do this as
a vector wise dot product.
But here I'm doing
it as multiplication.
Modulo a prime.
Prime has to be bigger than U,
maybe bigger or equal is fine.
Universe.
And then you take the
whole thing modulo em,
Now, this is universal but
it loses a factor of 2 here,
I believe, in general.
Because you take things
modulo prime and then
you take things modulo
whatever your table size is.
If you set your table
size to p that's great.
I think you get a factor of 1.
If you don't, you're essentially
losing possibly half the slots,
depending on how m and p
are related to each other.
So it's OK, but not great.
It's also considered
expensive because you
have do all this division,
which people don't like to do.
So there's a
fancier method which
is a times x shifted right
by log u minus log m.
This is when m and u are
powers of 2, which is
the case we kind of care about.
Usually your
universe is of size 2
to the word size of your
machine, 2 to the 32,
2 to the 64, however
bigger integers are.
So it's usually a power of 2.
It's fine to make your
table a power of 2.
We're probably going
to use table doubling.
So you just multiply and then
take the high order bits,
that's what this is saying.
So this is a method
more recent, 1997.
Whereas this one
goes back to 1979.
So '79, '97.
And it's also universal.
There's a lot of
universal hash functions.
I'm not going to list them all.
I'd rather get to stronger
properties than universality.
So the next one is called
k-wise independence.
This is harder to obtain.
And it implies universality.
So we want a family of
hash functions such that--
Maybe let's start with
just pairwise independence,
k equals 2.
Then what this is saying
is the probability
of your choice of hash function,
that the first key maps
to this slot, t1, and
the second key maps
to some other slot, t2.
For any two keys x1 and xk.
If your function was
random each of those
happens with probability 1
over m, they're independent.
So you get 1 over m to the
k, or 1 over m squared for k
equals 2.
Even in that situation
that's different from saying
the probability of 2 keys
being equal is 1 over m.
This would imply that.
But here there could still
be some co-dependence
between x and y.
Here there essentially can't be.
I mean, other than
this constant factor.
Pairwise independence means
every two guys are independent,
k-wise means every k
guys are independent
up to the constant factor.
So this is for distinct xi's.
Obviously if two
of them are equal
they're very likely to
hash to the same slot.
So you've got to forbid that.
OK, so an example of
such a hash function.
Here we just took a product.
In general you can take a
polynomial of degree k minus 1.
Evaluate that mod p.
And then if you want some,
modulo that to your table size.
So in particular if k
equals 2, we actually
have to do some work.
This function is not pairwise
independent, it is universal.
If you make it ax plus
b for random a and b,
then this becomes
pairwise independent.
In general, you want
three wise independent,
triple wise independent, you
need ax squared plus bx plus c
for random a, b's, and c's.
So these are arbitrary numbers
between 0 and p, I guess.
OK.
This is also old, 1981.
Wegman and Carter
introduced these two notions
in a couple of different papers.
This is an old idea.
This is, of course, expensive
in that we pay order k time
to evaluate it.
Also, there's a lot
of multiplications
and you have to do
everything modulo p.
So a lot of people have
worked on more efficient ways
to do k-wise independence.
And there two main
results on this.
Both of them achieve m to the
epsilon space, is not great.
One of them the query
time depends on k,
and it's uniform, and
reasonably practical
[? with ?] experiments.
The other one is constant query
for a logarithmic independence.
So this one is actually later.
It's by Thorpe and [? Tsang.
?] And this is by Siegel.
Both 2004, so fairly recent.
It takes a fair amount of space.
This paper proves that
to get constant query
time for logarithmic
independence
you'd need quite a bit of space
to store your hash function.
Keep in mind, these hash
functions only take--
well this is like k
log in bits to store.
So this is words of space.
So here we're only
spending k words
to store this hash function.
It's very small.
Here you need
something depending
on n, which is kind of
annoying, especially
if you want to be dynamic.
But statically you can get
constant query logarithmic wise
independence, but you have
to pay a lot in space.
There's more practical methods.
This is especially
practical for k
equals 5, which is a case
that we'll see is of interest.
Cool.
So this much space is
necessary if you want.
We'll see log wise independence
is the most we'll ever
require in this class.
And as far as I know,
in hashing in general.
So you don't need
to worry about more
than log wise independence.
All right, one more
hashing scheme.
It's called simple
tabulation hashing.
This is a simple idea.
It goes also back
to '81 but it's just
been analyzed last year.
So there's a lot of
results to report on it.
The idea is just
take your integer,
split it up into some base
so that there's exactly
c characters.
c is going to be a constant.
Then build a totally
random hash table.
This is the thing that
we couldn't afford.
But we're just going to
do it on each character.
So there's going to be
c of these hash tables.
And each of them is going to
have size u to the 1 over c.
So essentially we're getting u
to the epsilon space, which is
similar to these space bounds.
So again, not great, but it's
a really simple hash function.
Hash function is just going to
be you take your first table,
apply it to the first
character, x over that,
with the second table applied
to the second character,
and so on through
all the characters.
So the nice thing about
this is it's super simple.
You can imagine this
being done probably
in one instruction
on a fancy CPU.
if you convince people this
is a cool enough instruction
to have.
It's very simple to
implement circuit wide.
But in our model you have
to do all these operations
separately.
You're going to take
orders c time to compute.
And one thing that's
known about it
is that it's three independent,
three wise independent.
So it does kind of
fit in this model.
But three wise independence
is not very impressive.
A lot of the results we'll see
require log n independence.
But the cool thing is, roughly
speaking simple tabulation
hashing is almost as good
as log n wise independence
in all the hashing schemes
that we care about.
And so we'll get there,
exactly what that means.
So that was my overview of some
hash functions, these two guys.
Next we're going to
look at basic chaining.
Perfect hashing.
How many people
have seen perfect
hashing just to get a sense?
More than half.
Maybe 2/3.
All right, I should
do this really fast.
Chaining, this is the first
kind of hashing you usually see.
You have your hash
function, which
is mapping keys into slots.
If you have two keys
that go to the same slot
you store them as a linked list.
OK, if you don't have anything
in this slot, it's blank.
This is very easy.
If you look at a
particular slot t and call
the length of the chain
that you get there Ct.
You can look at the expected
length of that chain.
In general, it's just going
to be sum of the probability
that the keys map to that slot.
And then you sum over all keys.
This is just writing this
as a sum of indicator
random variables, and then
each linearity of expectation,
expectation of each of
the indicator variables
is probability.
So that is the expected number.
Here we just need to
compute the probability
each guy goes to each slot.
As long as your hash
function is uniform,
meaning that each of these
guys is equally likely
to be hashed to.
Well actually, we're looking
at a particular slot.
So we're essentially
using universality here.
Once we fix one slot
that we care about,
so let t be some h of
y that we care about,
then this is universality.
By universality we
know this is 1 over m.
And so this is 1 over n over m,
usually called the load factor.
And what we care about
is this is constant for m
equal theta n.
And so you use table
doubling to keep m theta n.
Boom, you've got expected
chain length constant.
But in the theory world
expected is a very weak bound.
What we want are high
probability bounds.
So let me tell you a little bit
about high probability bounds.
This, you may not
have seen as much.
Let's start with if your hash
function is totally random,
then your chain lengths will be
order log m over a log log n,
with high probability.
They are not constant.
In fact, you expect
the maximum chain
to be at least log
n over log log n.
I won't prove that here.
Instead, I'll prove
the upper bound.
So the claim is that while
in expectation each of them
is constant, variance
is essentially high.
Actually let's talk about
variance a little bit.
Sorry, I'm getting distracted.
So you might say, oh
OK, expectation is nice.
Let's look at variance.
Turns out variance is
constant for these chains.
There are various
definitions of variance.
But in particular the formula
I want to use is this one.
It writes it as
some expectations.
Now, this expected chain
length we know is constant.
So you square it,
it's still constant.
So that's sort of irrelevant.
The interesting part is what
is the expected squared chain
length.
Now this is going to depend
exactly on your hash function.
Let's analyze it
for totally random.
In general, we just need a
certain kind of symmetry here.
You can write I will look at the
expected squared chain lengths.
And instead, what I'd like to
do is just sum over all of them.
This is going to be
easier to analyze.
So this is expected
squared chain lengths.
If I sum over all chains and
then divide, take the average,
then I'll probably
get the expected chain
length of any individual.
As long as your hash
function is symmetric
all the keys are sort
of equally likely.
This will be true.
And then you could
just basically
apply a random
permutation to your keys
to make this true
if it isn't already.
Now this thing is
just the number
of pairs of keys that collide.
So you can forget about
slots, this is just the sum
overall pairs of keys
ij of the probability
that xi hashes to
the same spot as xj.
And that's something we
know by universality.
This is 1 over m.
Big O.
The number of
pairs is m squared.
So we get m squared times
1 over m, times 1 over m.
This is constant.
So the variance
is actually small.
It's not a good indicator of
how big our chains can get.
Because still, with time
probability one of the chains
will be log n over log log n.
It's just typical one won't be.
Let's prove the upper bound.
This uses Chernoff bounds.
This is a tail
bound, essentially.
I haven't probably defined
with high probability.
It's probably good to
remember, review this.
This means probability
at least 1 minus 1
over n to c where I get
to choose any constant c.
So high probability means
polynomially small failure
probability.
This is good because if you do
this polynomially many times
this property remains true.
You just up your constant
by however many times
you're going to use it.
So we prove these kinds of
bounds using Chernov, which
looks something like this.
e to the c minus 1
mu over c mu c mu.
So mu here is the mean.
The mean we've already
computed is constant.
The expectation of the
ct variable is constant.
So we want it to be not
much larger than that.
So say the probability that
it's some factor larger--
c doesn't have to be constant
here, sorry, maybe not
great terminology.
So the probability of ct is at
least some c times the mean,
is going to be at
most this exponential.
Which is a bit
annoying, or a bit ugly.
But in particular, if we plug in
c equals log n over log log n,
use that as our factor, which is
what we're concerned about here
then.
We get that this probability
is essentially dominated
by the bottom term here.
And this becomes
log n over log log n
to the power log
n over log log n.
So essentially, get 1 over that.
And if you take this bottom part
and put it into the exponent,
you get essentially log log n.
So this is something
like 1 over 2
to the log n over log
log n times log log n.
And the log log n's cancel.
And so this is
basically 1 over n.
And if you put a
constant in here
you can get a constant
in the exponent here.
So you can get failure
probability 1 over n to the c.
So get this with
high probability
bound as long as
you go up to a chain
length of log n over log log n.
It's not true otherwise.
So this is kind of depressing.
It's one reason we will
turn to perfect hashing,
some of the chains are long.
But there is a sense in
which this is not so bad.
So let me go to that.
I kind of want all these.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: What's that?
ERIK DEMAINE: Since
when is log n long.
Well--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Right, so
I mean, in some sense
the name of the
game here is we want
to beat binary search trees.
I didn't even mention what
problem we're solving.
We're solving the
dictionary problem, which
is sort of bunch of
keys, insert delete,
and search is now
just exact search.
I want to know is
this key in there?
If so, find some data
associated with it.
Which is something binary search
trees could do, n log n time.
And we've seen
various fancy ways
to try to make that better.
But in the worst case,
you need log n time
to do binary search trees.
We want to get to constant
as much as possible.
We want the hash function to be
evaluatable in constant time.
We want the queries to
be done in constant time.
If you have a long chain, you've
got to search the whole chain
and I don't want to spend
log n over log log n.
Because I said so.
Admittedly, log n over
log log n is not that big.
And furthermore,
the following holds.
This is a sense in
which it's not really
log n over log log n.
If we change the
model briefly and say,
well, suppose I have a cache
of the last log n items
that I searched for
in the hash table.
Then if you're
totally random, which
is something we
assumed here in order
to apply the Chernoff bound,
we needed that everything
was completely random.
Then you get a constant
amortized bound per operation.
So this is kind of funny.
In fact, all it's saying
this is easy to prove.
And it's not yet in any paper.
It's on Mihai Petrescu's
blog from 2011.
All right, we're here.
We're looking at
different chains.
So you access some chain,
then you access another chain,
then you access another chain.
If you're unlucky,
you'll hit the big chain
which cost log n
over over log log n
to touch, which is expensive.
But you could then put
all those guys into cache,
and if you happen to
keep probing there
you know it should be faster.
In general, you do
a bunch of searches.
OK, first I search for x1, then
I search for x2, x3, so on.
Cluster those into
groups theta log n.
OK, let's look at
the first log n
searches, then the next log
n searches, and analyze those
separately.
We're going to amortize
over that period of log n.
So if we look at theta log n--
actually, this is
written in a funny way.
You've got the data, just log n.
So I'm going to look at a
batch of log n operations.
And I claim that
the number of keys
that collide with them is theta
log n, with high probability.
If this is true, then
it's constant each.
If I can do log n operations
by visiting order log n total
chain items with
high probability,
then I just charge one each.
And so amortized over
this little log n window
of sort of smoothing the cost.
With high probability
now, not just expectation,
I get constant
amortized per operation.
So I should have said,
with high probability.
Why is this true?
It's essentially
the same argument.
Here this is normally called
a balls and bin argument.
So you're throwing balls,
which are your keys, randomly
into your bins,
which are your slots.
And the expectation is constant
probability to any one of them,
I mean any one of
them could go up
to log n over log log
n, high probability.
Over here, we're looking
at log n different slots
and taking the sum of balls that
fall into each of the slots.
And in expectation that's log
n, because it's constant each.
An expectation is
linear if you're taking
the sum over these log n bins.
So the expectation is log n.
So you apply Chernoff again.
Except now the mean is log n.
And then it suffices
to put c equals 2.
We can run through this.
So here we get the
mean is theta log n.
We expect there to
be log n items that
fall into these log n bins.
And so you just plug in c equals
2 to the Chernoff bound and you
get e to the log n--
which is kind of weird--
over 2 log n to the 2 log n.
So this thing is like
n to the log log n 2.
So this is big, way
bigger than this.
So this essentially disappears.
And in particular, this is
bigger than 1 over n to the c,
for any c.
So log log n is bigger
than any constant.
So you're done.
So that's just saying
the probability
that you're more than twice
the mean is very, very small.
So with high probability
there's only log n items
that fall in these log n bins.
So you just amortize,
boom, constant.
This is kind of a weird notion.
I've never actually seen
amortized with high probability
ever in a paper.
This is the first time it
seems like a useful concept.
So if you think log n
over log log n is bad,
this is a sense
in which it's OK.
Don't worry about it.
All right, but if you did worry
about it, next thing you do
is perfect hashing.
So, perfect hashing is
really just an embellishment.
This is also called FKS hashing.
From the authors, Friedman,
Komlosh, and [? Samaretti. ?]
This is from 1984, so old idea.
You just take
chaining, but instead
of storing your chains
in a linked list,
store them in a hash table.
Simple idea.
There's one clever trick.
You store it in
a big hash table.
Hash table of size
theta ct squared.
Now this looks like a
problem because that's
going to be quadratic space,
in the worst case, if everybody
hashes to the same chain.
But we know that
chains are pretty
small with high probability.
So turns out this is OK.
The space is sum of ct squared.
And that's something we
actually computed already,
except I erased it.
How convenient of me.
It was right here.
I can still barely read it.
When we computed the variance.
We can do it again it's
not really that hard.
This is the number of
pairs of keys that collide.
And so there's n squared
pairs and each of them
has a probability 1 over
me of colliding if you
have a universal hash function.
So this is n squared
over m, which
if m is within a constant
factor of n, is linear.
So linear space in expectation.
Expected amount of
space is linear.
I won't try to do with high
probability bound here.
What else can I say?
You have to play a similar
trick when you're actually
building these hash tables.
All right, so why
do we use n squared?
Because of the birthday paradox.
So if you have a hash table of
size n squared, essentially,
or ct squared with
high probability
or constant probability you
don't get any collisions.
Why?
Because then they expected
number of collisions in ct.
Well, there's ct pairs
or ct squared pairs.
Each of them, if you're
using universal hashing,
had a probability of 1 over
ct squared of happening.
Because that's the
table size, 1 over m.
So this is constant.
And if we set the
constants right,
I get to set this theta
to be whatever I want.
I get this to be less than 1/2.
If the expected number of
collisions is less than 1/2,
then the probability that
the number of collisions is 0
is at least a 1/2.
This is Markov's
inequality, in particular.
The probability number of
collisions is at least 1
is at most the expectation
over 1, so which is 1/2.
So you try to build this table.
If you have 0
collisions you're happy.
You go on to the next one.
If you don't have 0
collisions, just try again.
So in an expected
constant number of trials
you're flipping
a coin each time.
Eventually you'll get heads.
Then you can build this table.
And then you have 0 collisions.
So we always want them
to be collision free.
So in an expected linear
time you can build this table
and it will have
expected linear space.
In fact, if it doesn't
have linear space
you can just try the
whole thing over again.
So in expected
linear time you'll
build a guaranteed
linear space structure.
The nice thing about
perfect hashing
is you're doing two hash
de-references and that's it.
So the query is
constant deterministic.
Queries are now deterministic,
only updates are randomized.
I didn't talk about updates.
I talked about building.
The construction
here is randomized,
queries are constant
deterministic.
Now, you can make this dynamic
in pretty much the obvious way
you say, OK, I want to insert.
So I compute which of the, it's
essentially two level hashing.
So first you figure out where
it fits in the big hash table,
then you find the corresponding
chain, which is now hash table,
and you insert into
that hash table.
So it's the obvious thing.
The trouble is you might get a
collision in that hash table.
If you get a collision, you
rebuild that hash table.
Probability of the collision
happening is essentially small.
It's going to remain small
because of this argument.
Because we know the expected
number of collisions
remains small unless that
chain gets really big.
So if the chain grows
by a factor of 2,
then generally you have
to rebuild the table.
But if your chain length
grows by a factor of 2,
then you rebuild your table
to have factor 4 size larger
because it's ct squared.
And in general, you
maintain that the table
is sized for a chain of roughly
the correct chain length
within a constant factor.
And you do doubling and halving
in the usual way, like b-tree.
Or, I guess it's
table doubling really.
And it will be
constant amortized
expected per operation.
And there's a fancy way
to make this constant
with high probability
per insert and delete,
which I have not read.
But it's by [? Desfil ?]
Binger and [? Meyer ?]
[? Ofterheight, ?] 1990.
So, easy to make this
expected amortized.
With more effort
you could make it
with high probability
per operation.
That is trickier.
Cool.
I actually skipped one
thing with chaining,
which I wanted to talk about.
So this analysis was fine,
it just used universality.
This cache analysis,
I said totally random.
This analysis, I
said totally random.
What about real hash functions?
We can't use totally random.
What about universal k-wise
independent simple tabulation
hashing, just for chaining?
OK, and similar things hold
for perfect hashing, I think.
I'm not sure if
they're all known.
Oh, sorry, perfect hashing.
In expectation everything's
fine, just with universal.
So we've already done
that with universal.
What about chaining?
How big can the chains get?
I said log n over log log
with a high probability,
but our analysis
used Chernoff bound.
That's only true for
Bernoulli trials.
It was only true for totally
random hash functions.
It turns out same
is true if you have
a log n over log log n wise
independent hash function.
So this is kind of annoying.
If you want this to be true
you need a lot of independence.
And it's hard to get
log n independence.
There is a way to get constant,
but it needed a lot of space.
That was this one, which
is not so thrilling.
It's also kind of complicated.
So if you don't mind
the space but you just
want it to be simpler, you can
use simple tabulation hashing.
Both of these, the same chain
analysis turns out to work.
So this is fairly old.
This is from 1995.
This is from last year.
So if you just use this
simple tabulation hashing,
still has a lot of
space, e to the epsilon.
But very simple to implement.
Then still, the chain lengths
are as you expect them to be.
And I believe that carries
over to this caching argument,
but I haven't checked it.
All right.
Great, I think we're now happy.
We've talked about
real hash functions
for chaining and
perfect hashing.
Next thing we're going to
talk about is linear probing.
I mean, in some sense we have
good theoretical answers now.
We can do constant
expected amortized even
with constant
deterministic queries.
But we're greedy, or people
like to implement all sorts
of different hashing schemes.
Perfect hashing is
pretty rare in practice.
Why?
I guess, because you have to
hash twice instead of once
and that's just more expensive.
So what about the
simpler hashing schemes?
Simple tabulation hashing
is nice and simple,
but what about linear probing?
That's really simple.
Linear probing is
either the first
or the second hashing
scheme you learned.
You store things in a table.
The hash function
tells you where to go.
If that's full, you just
go to the next spot.
If that's full, you
go to the next spot
till you find an empty slot
and then you put x there.
So if there's some y
and z here, that that's
where you end up putting it.
Everyone knows
linear probing is bad
because the rich get richer.
It's like the
parking lot problem.
If you get big runs of elements
they're more likely to get hit,
so they're going to grow
even faster and get worse.
So you should never
use linear probing.
Has everyone learned that?
It's all false, however.
Linear probing is
actually really good.
And first indication is it's
really good in practice.
There's this small
experiment by Mihai Petrescu,
who was an undergrad
and PhD student here.
He's working on AT&T now.
And he was doing
some experiments
and he found that in
practice on a network router
linear probing costs 10% more
time than a memory access.
So, basically free.
Why?
You just set m to be 2 times
n, or 1 plus epsilon times
n, whatever.
It actually works really well.
And I'd like to convince you
that it works really well.
Now, first let me
tell you some things.
The idea that it works
really well is old.
For a totally
random hash function
you require constant
time per operation.
And Knuth actually
showed this first in 1962
in a technical report.
The answer ends up being
1 over epsilon squared.
Now you might say,
1 over epsilon
squared, oh that's really bad.
And there are other
schemes that achieve 1
over epsilon, which is better.
But what's a little
bit of space, right?
I mean, just set epsilon
to 1, you're done.
So I think linear probing
was bad when we really
were tight on space.
But when you can afford a factor
of 2, linear probing is great.
That's the bottom line.
Now, this is totally
random, not so useful.
What about all these
other hash functions?
Like universal,
turns out universal
with the universal
hash function,
linear probing is
really, really bad.
And that's why it
gets a bad rap.
But some good news.
OK, first result was
log n wise independence.
This is extremely
strong but it also
implies constant
expected per operation.
Not very exciting.
The big breakthrough was in
2007 that five-wise independence
is enough.
And this is why
this paper, Thorpe
was focusing in particular
on the case of k equals 4.
Actually, they were
doing k equals 4,
but they solved 5
at the same time.
And so this was a very
highly optimized, practical,
all that good stuff.
Get five-wise independence,
admittedly with some space.
But it's pretty cool.
So this is enough to
get constant expected.
I shouldn't write order
1, because I'm not writing
the dependence on epsilon here.
I don't know exactly what it is.
But it's some constant
depending on epsilon.
And then this turns
out to be tight.
There are four-wise
independent hash functions,
including I think the
polynomial ones that we did.
These guys that are really bad.
You can get really bad.
They're as bad as
binary search trees.
You can get constant expected.
So you really need
five-wise independence.
It's kind of weird,
but it's true.
And the other fun fact is that
simple tabulation hashing also
achieves constant.
And here it's known that it's
also 1 over epsilon squared.
So it's just as good as totally
random simple tabulation
hashing.
Which is nice because
again, this is simple.
Takes a bit of space but both
of these have that property.
And so these are
good ways to use
linear probing in particular.
So you really need
a good hash function
for linear probing to work out.
If you use the universal
hash function like a times
x mod p mod m it will fail.
But if you use a good hash
function, which we're now
getting to the point--
I mean, this is super
simple to implement.
It should work fine.
I think would be a
neat project to take
a Python or something that had
hash tables deep inside it,
replace--
I think they use quadratic
probing and universal hash
functions.
If you instead use linear
probing and simple tabulation
hashing, might do the same,
might do better, I don't know.
It's interesting.
It would be a
project to try out.
Cool.
Well, I just quoted results.
What I'd like to do is prove
something like this to you.
Totally random hash functions
imply some constant expected.
I won't try to work out
the dependence on epsilon
because it's actually a pretty
clean proof, it looks nice.
Very data structures-y.
I'm not going to
cover Knut's proof.
I'm essentially
covering this proof.
In this paper
five-wise independence
implies constant expected.
They re-prove the
totally random case
and strengthen it, analyze
the independence they need.
Let's just do totally
random unbiased constant
expected for linear probing.
We obviously know how to do
constant expected already
with other fancy techniques.
But linear probing
seems really bad.
Yet I claim, not so much.
And we're going to assume
m is at least 3 times n.
That will just make
the analysis cleaner.
But it does hold
for 1 plus epsilon.
OK, so here's the idea.
We're going to take our array,
our hash table, it's an array.
And build a binary tree
on it because that's
what we like to do.
We do this every
lecture pretty much.
This is kind of like ordered
file maintenance, I guess.
This is just a conceptual tree.
I mean, you're not even
defining an algorithm
based on this because the
algorithm is linear probing.
You go into somewhere.
You hop, hop, hop, hop until
you find a blank space.
You put your item there.
OK, but each of these
nodes defines an interval
in the array, as we know.
So I'm going to call
a node dangerous,
essentially if its
density is at least 2/3.
But not in the literal sense
because there's a little bit
of a subtlety here.
There's the location
where a key wants to live,
which is h of that key.
And there's the location
that it ended up living.
I care more about the
first one because that's
what I understand.
h of x, that's going to be nice.
It's totally random.
So h of x is random
independent of everything else.
Great.
Where x ends up being,
that depends on other keys
and it depends on
this linear thing
which I'm trying to understand.
So I just want to talk
about the number of keys
that hash via h to the interval
if that is at least 2/3 times
the length of the interval.
This is the number of slots
that are actually there.
We expect the number of keys
that hash via h to the interval
to be 1/2.
So the expectation would be
1/3 the length the interval.
If it happens to be
2/3 it could happen
because of high
probability, whatever.
That's a dangerous node.
That's the definition.
Those ones we worry
will be very expensive.
And we worry that we're
going to get super clustering
and then get these
giant runs, and so on.
So, one thing I
want to compute was
what's the probability
of this happening.
Probability of a
node being dangerous.
Well, we can again use
Chernoff bounds here
because we're in a
totally random situation.
So this is the probability
that the number
of things that went
there was bigger
than twice the expectation.
The expectation is 1/2,
2/3 is twice of 1/3.
So this is the probability that
you're at least twice the mean,
which by Chernoff is small.
It comes out to e to
the mu over 2 to 2 mu.
So this is e over 4 to the mu.
You can check e.
It's 2.71828.
So this is less than 1,
kind of roughly a half-ish.
So this is good.
This is something like
1 over 2 to the mu.
What's mu?
mu is 1/3 2 to the h
for a height h node.
It depends on how high you are.
If you're at a leaf h is 0, so
you expect 1/3 of an element
there.
As you go up you
expect more elements
to hash there, of course.
OK, so this gives
us some measure
in terms of this h
of what's going on.
But it's actually
doubly exponential in h.
So this is a very
small probability.
You go up a few levels.
Like, after log
log n levels it's
a polynomially small
probability of happening.
Because then 2 to the
log log n is log n.
And then e over 4 to
the log n is about n.
OK.
But at small levels this
may happen, near the leaves.
All right, so now I want to
look at a run in the table.
These are the things I
have trouble thinking about
because runs tend to get
bigger, and we worry about them.
This is now as items are
actually stored at the table,
when do I have a bunch of
consecutive items in there
that happen to end up
in consecutive slots?
So I'm worried about
how long that run is.
So let's look at its
logarithm and round
to the nearest power of 2.
So let's say it has
length about 2 to the l.
Sorry, plus 1.
All right, between 2 to the
l and 2 to the l plus 1.
OK, look at that.
And it's spanned by some
number of nodes of height h
equals l minus 3.
OK, so there's some interval
that happens to be a run,
meaning all of these
slots are occupied.
And that's 2 to the
2, I guess, since I
got to level negative 1.
A little hard to do
in a small picture.
But we're worried about
when this is really
big more than some constant.
OK, so let's suppose I
was looking at this level.
Then this interval is
spanned, in particular,
by these two nodes.
Now it's a little
sloppy because this node
contains some non-interval,
non-run stuff,
and so does this one.
At the next level down it would
be this way one, this one,
and this one, which is
a little more precise.
But it's never going
to be quite perfect.
But just take all
the nodes you need
to completely cover the run.
Then this will be at least eight
nodes because the length is
1 to the l.
We went three levels
down, 2 to the 3 is 8.
So if it's perfectly aligned
it will be exactly 8 nodes.
In the worst case, it
could be as much as 17.
Because potentially,
we're 2 to the l plus 1,
which means we have 16 nodes
if we're perfectly aligned.
But then if you shift
if over it might be
one more because of the slot.
OK, but some constant
number of nodes.
It's important that
it's at least eight.
That's what we need.
Actually, we just need
that's it at least five,
but eight is the nearest
power of two rounding up.
Cool.
So, there they are.
Now, I want to look at
the first four nodes
of these eight to 12 nodes.
So first meaning leftmost.
Earliest in the run.
So if you think about
them, so there's
some four nodes each
of them spans some--
I should draw these properly.
What we know is that these guys
are entirely filled with items.
The run occupies here.
It's got to be at least one item
into here, but the rest of this
could be empty.
And the interval keeps
going to the right
so we know that all of
these are completely
filled with items somehow.
So let's start with how
many there are, I guess.
They span more than three times
2 to the h slots of the run.
So somehow 3 times 2 to the h--
because there's three of them
that are completely filled,
otherwise it would be four.
Somehow three times two
to the h items ended here.
Now, how did they end up here?
Notice there's a blank
space right here.
By definition this was
the beginning of a run.
Meaning the previous
slot is empty.
Which means all of the
keys that wanted to live
from here to the left got to.
So if we're just thinking
about the keys that ended up
in this interval, they had to
initially hash to somewhere
in here.
h put them somewhere
in this interval
and then they may have
moved to the right,
but they never move to
the left in linear hashing
if you're not completely full.
So because there was a blank
spot here none of these keys
could have fallen over
to here, no deletions.
So you're doing insertions.
They may have just
spread it out,
and they made sconces have
gone farther to the right,
or they may filled in
gaps, whatever, but h
put them in this interval.
Now, I claim that in fact,
at least one of these nodes
must be dangerous.
Now dangerous is tricky,
because dangerous is talking
about where h puts nodes.
But we just said, got to be at
least three times two to the h
keys, where h put them
within these four nodes,
otherwise they wouldn't
have filled in here.
Now, if none of those
nodes were dangerous,
then we'll get a contradiction.
Because none of
them were dangerous
this means at most
4 times 2/3 times 2
to the h keys hash
via h to them.
Why?
Because there's
four of the nodes.
Each of them, if it's not
dangerous, has at most 2/3
of its size keys hashing there.
4 times 2/3 is 8/3, which is
less than 9/3, which is 3.
OK, so this would
be a contradiction
because we just argued that at
least 3 times 2 to the h nodes
have to hash via h to
somewhere in these nodes.
They might hash here and
then fallen over to here.
So there is this kind of,
things can move to the right,
we've got to worry about it.
But just look three
levels up and it's OK.
So one of these nodes, not
necessarily all of them,
are dangerous.
And we can use that to
finish our analysis.
This is good news
because it says
that if we have a run,
which is something that's
hard to think about because
nodes are moving around
to form a run, so keys are
moving around to form a run,
we can charge it to
a dangerous node.
Which is easy to think
about because that's just
talking about where keys hash
via h, and h is totally random.
There's a loss of a
factor of 17, potentially.
But it's a constant
factor, no big deal.
If we look at the probability
that the length of a run,
say containing some key x,
has length between 2 to the l
and to the l plus
1, this is going
to be at most 17 times the
probability of a node at height
l minus 3 is dangerous.
Because we know one of them
is, and so just to be sloppy
it's at most the sum of the
probabilities that any of them
is.
Then potentially there's
a run of that length.
And so union bound it's at
most 17 times probability
of this happening.
Now all nodes look the
same because we have
a totally random hash function.
So we just say any node
at height l minus 3.
We already computed
that probability.
That was this.
Probability of being dangerous
was e over 4 to the 1/3 2
to the h.
So this is going to be at most
17 times e over 4 to the 2
to the l minus 3 power.
Again, doubly exponential in l.
So if we want to compute
the expected run length
we can just expand
out the definition.
Well, let's round
it to powers of 2.
It could be the run
length is about 2
to the l within a constant
factor of 2 to the l.
So it's going to be that
times this probability.
But this thing is basically
1 over 2 to the 2 to the l.
And so the whole
thing is constant.
This is l.
I mean, l could go to infinity.
I don't really care.
I mean, this gets dwarfed
by the double exponential.
This is super geometric.
So a very low probability
of getting long runs.
As we said, after
a log log n size--
yeah, it's very unlikely
to run longer than log n.
We proved that in particular.
But in particular, you compute
the expected run length,
it's constant.
OK, now this of course
assumed totally random.
It's harder to prove--
where were we.
Somewhere.
Linear probing.
It's harder to prove five-wise
independence is enough,
but it's true.
And it's much harder to
prove simple tabulation
hashing works, but it's true.
So we can use them.
This gives you some intuition
for why it's really not
that bad.
And similar proof
techniques are used
for the five-wise independence.
Other fun facts.
You can do similar caching
trick that we did before.
Again, the worst run is going
to be log, or log over log log.
I don't have it written here.
But if you cache the last--
it's not quite enough
to do the last log n.
But if you cache the last log
to the 1 plus epsilon n queries.
It's a little bit more.
Then you can generalize
this argument.
And so at least for totally
random hash functions
you get constant amortize
with high probability.
This weird thing that
I've never seen before.
But it's comforting because
it's expected bounds are not
so great, but you get it
with high probability bound
as long as you're willing
to average over log to the 1
plus epsilon different queries.
As long as you
can remember them.
And the proof is
basically the same.
Except now instead of looking
at the length of a run
containing x, you're looking
at the length of the run
containing one of these log
to the 1 plus epsilon n nodes.
That's your batch.
And you do the same thing.
But now do it with high
probability analysis.
But again, because
the expectation is now
bigger than log,
expect there to be
a lot of fairly long runs here.
But that's OK, because
on average is good.
You expect to pay log to
the 1 plus epsilon for log
to the 1 plus epsilon queries.
And so then you divide and
amortize and you're done.
It's a little bit more
details in the notes about
that if you want to read.
I want to do one more
topic, unless there are
questions about linear probing.
So, yeah?
AUDIENCE: So, could you motivate
why the [INAUDIBLE] value of mu
is the mean for
whatever quantity?
ERIK DEMAINE: So mu is defined
to be the mean of whatever
quantity we're analyzing.
And the Chernoff bounds
says, probability
that you're at least
something times the mean is
the formula we wrote last time.
Now here, we're measuring--
I didn't write what
the left-hand side was.
But here we're measuring
what's the probability
that the number of keys that
hash via h to the interval
is at least 2/3 the
length of the interval.
Now, let's say m equals 3m then
the expected number of keys
that hash via h to interval
is 1/3 times the length
of the interval.
Because we have a
totally random thing,
and we have a density
of 1/3 overall.
So you expect there
to be 1/3 and so
dangerous is when you're
more than twice that.
And so it's twice mu.
Mu is, in this case, 1/3
the length the interval.
And that's why I wrote that.
AUDIENCE: So this comes
from the m squared.
[INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah,
it comes from m
equals 3m and totally random.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, OK
let's make this equal.
Make this more formal.
It's an assumption, anyway,
to simplify the proof.
Good.
Change that in the notes too.
Cool.
So then the
expectation is exactly
1/3 instead of at most 1/3.
So it's all a little cleaner.
Of course, this all works
when m is at least 1
plus epsilon times
n, but then you
get a dependence on epsilon.
Other questions?
So bottom line is linear
probing is actually good.
Quadratic probing, double
hashing, all those fancy things
are also good.
But they're really
tuned for the case
when your table is almost full.
They get a better
dependence on epsilon,
which is how close
to the bound you are.
And so if you're constant
factor away from space bound,
linear probing is just fine.
As long as you have enough
independence, admittedly.
Double hashing, I
believe, gets around that.
It does not need so
much independence.
OK.
Instead of going
to double hashing,
I'm going to go to something
kind of related double hashing,
which is cuckoo hashing.
Cuckoo hashing is a weird idea.
It's kind of a more extreme
form of perfect hashing.
It says, look, perfect
hashing did two hash queries.
So I did one hash evaluation
and another hash evaluation
followed it, which is OK.
But again, I want my queries to
only do two things, two probes.
So it's going to take
that concept of just two
and actually use
two hash tables.
So you've got B over here,
I've got A over here.
And if you have a
key x, you hash it
to a particular spot in
A via g, and you hash it
to a particular spot in B via
H. So you have two hash tables,
two hash functions.
To do a query you
look at A of g of x,
and you look at B of h of x.
Oh sorry, I forgot to mention.
The other great thing
about linear probing
is that it's cache
performance is so great.
This is why it runs
so fast in practice.
Why it's only 10% slower
than a memory access.
Because once you
access a single slot,
whole you get B slots in
a cache with block size B.
So most of the time, because
your runs are very short,
you will find your
answer immediately.
So that's why we kind
of prefer linear probing
in practice over all
the other schemes I'm
going to talk about.
Well, cuckoo
hashing is all right
because it's only going to look
at two places and that's it.
Doesn't go anywhere else.
I guess with perfect hashing
the thing is you have
more than two hash functions.
You have the first
hash function which
sends you to the first table.
Then you look up a
second hash function.
Using that hash function
you rehash your value x.
Downside of that is you
can't compare those two
hash functions in parallel.
So if you're like
two cores, you could
compute these two in
parallel, look them
both up simultaneously.
So in that sense you
save a factor of 2
with some parallelism.
Now, the weird thing is
the way we do an insertion.
You try to put it in the
A slot, or the B slot.
If either of them is
empty you're golden.
If neither of them
are empty, you've
got to kick out whoever's there.
So let's say if you kicked
out y from it's A slot.
So we ended up
putting x in this one,
so we end up kicking y
from wherever it belonged.
Then you move it to B of h of y.
There's only one other
place that that item can go,
so you put it there instead.
In general, I think about A key
it has two places it can go.
There's some slot in
A, some slot in B.
You can think of this as an
edge in a bipartite graph.
So make vertices
for the A slots,
vertices for the B slots.
Each edge is an item on a key.
Key Can only live one
spot in A, one spot in B
for this query to work.
So what's happening
is if both of these
are full you take
whoever is currently here
and put them over in
their corresponding slot
over in B. Now, that
one might be full,
which means you've got to
kick that guy to wherever
he belongs in A, and so on.
If eventually you find an
empty slot, great, you're done.
Just chain reaction
of cuckoo steps
where the bird's going
from in and out, or from A
to B, vice a versa.
If it terminates, you're happy.
It doesn't terminate,
you're in trouble
because you might get a cycle,
or a few failure situations.
In that case you're screwed.
There is no cuckoo
hash table that
works for your set of keys.
In that case, you pick
another hash function,
rebuild from scratch.
So it's kind of a
weird hashing scheme
because it can
fail catastrophic.
Fortunately, it doesn't
happen too often.
It still rubs me a funny way.
I don't know what
to say about it.
OK, so you lose a
factor of 2 in space.
2 deterministic
probes for a query.
That's good news.
All right, now we get
to, what about updates?
So if it's fully random
or log n-wise independent,
then you get a constant expected
update, which is what we want.
Even with the rebuilding cost.
So you'll have to rebuild about
every n squared insertions
you do.
The way they say this
is there's a 1 over n
build failure probability.
There's a 1 over n chance
that your key set will
be completely unsustainable.
If you want to put all n keys
into this table there's a 1
over n chance that
it will be impossible
and then you have to start over.
So amortize per insertion,
that's about 1 over n squared.
Insertions you can do before
the whole thing falls apart
and you have to rebuild.
So it's definitely
going to be this should
be amortize expected, I guess.
However you want
to think about it.
But it's another way to do
constant amortized expected.
Cool.
The other thing that's known
is that six-wise independence
is not enough.
This was actually a
project in this class,
I believe the first time
it was offered in 2003.
Six-wise independence
is not sufficient to get
constant expected bound.
It will actually fail
with high probability
if you only have
six-wise independence.
What's not known is, do you
need constant Independence?
Or log n independence?
With log n, very low
failure probability.
With six-wise, high
probability you fail.
Like, you fail with
probability 1 minus 1 over n.
Not so good.
Some good news is simple
tabulation hashing.
Means you will fail to build
with probability not 1 over n,
but 1 over n to the 1/3 power.
And this is theta.
This is tight.
It's almost as good as this.
We really only
need constant here.
This is to build
the entire table.
So in this case you can
insert like n to the 4
those items before your
table self-destructs.
So simple tabulation hashing
is, again, pretty good.
That's I think
the hardest result
in this paper from last year.
So I do have a
proof of this one.
Something like that.
Or part of a proof.
So me give you a rough
idea how this works.
So if you're a fully
random hash function.
The main concern is that what
if this path is really long.
I claim that if an insert
follows a path of length k,
or the probability
of this happening,
is actually at most
1 over 2 to the k.
It's very small.
Exponentially small in k.
I just want to sketch how
this works because it's
a cool argument that's actually
in this simple tabulation
paper.
So the idea is the following.
You have some really long path.
What I'm going to
give you is a way
to encode the hash functions.
There's hash functions g and h.
Each of them has n values.
Each of those values
is log m bits.
So if I just wrote them
down the obvious way,
it's 2 n log m bits to write
down those hash functions.
Now we're assuming these
are totally random hash
functions, which means
you need this many bits.
But I claim that if you
follow a path of length k,
I can find a new
encoding scheme, a way
to write down g and h
that is basically minus k.
This many bits minus k.
I get to save k bits.
Now, it turns out
that can happen
but it happens only with
probability 1 over 2 to the k.
This is an information
theoretic argument.
You might get lucky.
And the g's and h's
you're trying to encode
can be done with fewer
bits, k fewer bits.
But that will only happen with
probability 1 over 2 to the k
if g and h are totally random.
So how do you do it?
Basically, I want
to encode the things
on the path slightly cheaper.
I'm going to save one
bit per node on the path.
So what do I need to do?
Well, the idea is OK, I
will start by writing down
this hash value.
This takes log m bits to
write down that hash value.
Then I'll write down
this hash value.
That takes a log
m bit, log m bits.
Generally there's going to be
roughly k log n to write down
all of the node hash values.
Then I need to say
that it's actually
x, this particular key that
corresponds to this edge.
So I've got to write that down.
That's going to
take a log n bits
to say that x is the
guy for the first edge,
then y is the key that
corresponds to the second edge
of the path, then z, then w.
But nicely, things
are ordered here.
So it only takes
me to log n, k log
n to write down all these guys.
So I get k times
log m plus log n.
Now if m is 2 times n, this
is k times 2 log m minus 1.
So I get one bit of savings
per k, per thing in the path.
Essentially because
it's easier for me
to write down these
labels to say,
oh, it's the key x
that's going here.
Instead of having to write down
slot names all the time, which
cost log m bits, writing
down key names only
takes log n bits,
which is a savings
of 1 bit per thing on the path.
And so that was a quick
sketch of how this proof goes.
It's kind of neat,
information theoretic argument
why the paths can't get long.
You then have to worry
about cycles and things that
look like this.
That's kind of messy.
But same kind of
argument generalizes.
So that was your quick overview
of lots of hashing stuff.